- [Man] Let's move.
Sound, we're good?
Speed.
Four, three, two.
- Welcome to Late Night Show.
That's you.
That's the applause.
(group laughter)
(triumphant rock music)
- [Gary] What if I told
you this was the last
Monday morning of your life?
- [Gary] Thank you.
Where we going?
Hello.
- [Man 2] Hey. How you doin'?
- I'm in a funny place where
I'm just not scared,
I'm just not worried about,
I have this weird,
I could care less what
anybody thinks and
I genuinely care what
everybody thinks.
You know, it's the kind of this
really Ying and Yang and so
I just realized that so many of
you are scared to fail because
your dad's gonna make
you feel bad about it.
I have empathy for that.
That sucks.
Or your husband is
going to say I told you so.
I'm very fascinated by negative
energy within our ecosystem that
is not cut out-able.
- Hmmm.
- You can get rid of your
acquaintance that's a dick face.
Right? But when your mom's the
dick face, you're in trouble.
- Yeah.
- And so I've been trying to
have this conversation of who
are you scared to fail in
front of and I gotta tell you in
one-on-ones or meet-ups
where the content has come from,
that's the beauty
of doing a vlog.
- Yeah.
- Content happens
in these moments
that I would've
never thought of.
It's captured, it resonates,
I react to the reaction of the
audience and I start trying to
force myself to
understand it better.
Awesome, thanks for having me.
- Thank you so much. Thank you.
- Thank you, guys.
(applause)
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Woman] So, I literally just
booked a flight
yesterday at 3PM.
- That's so amazing.
- I had to, you want
to know a funny story?
I was like hey, I'm
going to be in New York.
I was going to be
here the next day.
I just wanted to go see the
office outside, if I could step
inside it'd be amazing and you
actually answered and were like
hey, email Matt.
- Mhmmm.
- I email Matt right
away and he answered me.
Be here at four or
something, I forgot.
Dude, my flight gets delayed
'cause I landed the same day.
I landed I ran through Newark,
I ran, I went on the, thank you,
I drop my bags at the hotel.
I dropped everything,
my friends are there,
I grab the train from Jersey--
- Yes.
- to here.
- By myself, never
been here before.
- You're amazing.
- I took two trains and a
cab and I never made it.
- How about this?
- This is amazing.
- Now we get to do this.
- Have a good one.
- We'll see you in a bit.
("Lustt" by LRYBRDBTZ)
What's cooking, sister?
Monday at 7AM I have a pretty
hard-core finance meeting and
by the way it just so
black and white.
Do you know what I mean?
If you have an account
that 90% of the energy,
forget about the scope,
forget about anything else,
if 90% of the energy
is based on sales,
conversion digital sales,
it's just not,
I'm not doing a good job of
putting the best players in the
best position to succeed.
The good news is, and I think
you know this about me,
like I think what makes me
pretty successful is I ideate
and I adjust and
I'm not willing to,
I'm not scared to say
okay that's not right.
I'm doing this.
You know?
I'm not ideological
around my own shit.
You'd never really do know if
the CEO has a real pull in the
trenches and I think that's
something I do pretty well.
What I love about this is it's
one click to get into
their push notification.
- [Andy] Yeah.
- But then it's like to wow,
you think you're building a good
business then you're on,
it's like old email.
It's so valuable, the attention
right now, and I don't have and
I don't want to build the app to
like do the alternate
version to this.
This is the low cost way to get
the best value of what apps can
do for most people.
Okay, I need to run.
- [Emily] Alright.
- Everybody knows what to do.
- Cool.
- How you doin'? Been a while.
- Good, man.
It has, how you been?
It's great to see you, man.
The biggest comment I get from
people when they come in to this
office is how loosey-goosey
and not tense it feels when
people come to my company.
Everybody likes to talk about,
you know when I do this vlog
everybody's like sometimes
somebody will come in a razz me
they're like you do anything.
No, no, no I don't do
anything the way you define it.
Yes, I do not go
outside and shovel.
Yes, I'm not sitting on my
computer in Final Cut
and editing.
I'm doing the
thing that matters.
- Alright.
- [Gary] Have a great, man.
I love it.
How are you?
- [Rachel] I'm so good.
- Good.
- [Rachel] I'm so
excited to be here.
- Thank you.
What's cooking?
- [Rachel] Okay, so the start
up is LoveStories TV and we're
building the first and largest
library of real wedding videos.
- [Gary] Of real what?
- Wedding videos.
People are hiring a videographer
for everything they used to hire
a photographer for.
- 100%.
- It's not just weddings.
It's engagements, it's
proposals, it's gender reveals,
it's day of birth,
it's Bar Mitzvahs.
- [Gary] This is how
every human being is
going to do
everything about everything.
Everybody's gonna have a DRock.
- [Rachel] Exact,
so my philosophy--
- Except I think eventually
DRock's gonna be a Pokémon ball.
You throw it up in the air
just follows you around.
- [Rachel] Yeah.
But someone still
has, it's the editing.
- [Gary] Only the editing.
- [Rachel] Exactly.
- Yeah, everybody loves DRock.
It's Tyler. (laughs)
For example, I can
really tell when DRock edits
versus when Tyler edits and
that's the storytelling.
- [Rachel] A million--
- [Gary] And the
amazing content.
So I think what you
need to do is one,
on step one, go win that.
VaynerMedia does everything
but everybody but we won
social media first to be the
gateway drug to everything.
- [Rachel] Right, right, right.
- Got it?
- [Rachel] Yep.
- You've already won this in
theory, now actually win it.
- [Rachel] Mhmmm.
- And then when
you actually win it,
is be the number
one ecosystem for it.
- Great.
- Okay.
- Thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you.
- You're welcome.
Have a great day.
- It was really fun to meet you.
- [DRock] It was
great meeting you.
("Jasper" by LRYBRDBTZ)
- [Alexei] When, that's more
a question out of curiosity,
how do you get people to
be honest with you?
As in, you, GaryVee,
like who's gonna say,
"No Gary, you're wrong"?
- [Gary] People say it.
- You're not seeing
this through when--
- I think you're right.
You try to make
people feel safe.
- Yeah.
- I'm tough because I'm a good
debater and I'm logical and
I'm very much only talking
about my own shit
that I'm talented in.
So the reason I don't, like a
lot of people are like you're
surrounded by yes-men I'm
like yeah 'cause you only see me
talking about my great skill.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's already getting
into another conversation.
- Yeah, exactly.
You want to talk
about development?
I can be like yeah, I like PHP.
You're like no Gary, Ruby.
Here's why.
I'm like oh, you know?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So I think that,
I think you have to
context which conversations.
- [Alexei] Yeah. Yeah and
it's true there would be--
- [Gary] So, I'll
give you a good example.
- [Alexei] Yeah?
- [Gary] A lot of people come in
and try to challenge me because
they think a lot of people don't
challenge me and they're gonna
bring value and they're gonna
stand out by challenging me.
- [Alexei] Yeah.
- [Gary] The problem is if
they're wrong in what
they're saying, they lose.
- [Alexei] Yeah, yeah.
- [Gary] When people leave
comments on my show or other
things and they're
like, "This is boring."
I'm like yes.
I'm like yep.
I'm gonna bore the shit out of
you guys for the rest of your
life because I--
- Until I go to my
my funeral, I know.
- I just don't believe
in that many things.
I'm not gonna make a new pillar.
- [Woman 2] Right.
- There's interpretations
of those tried-and-true.
- [Woman 2] And
addressing that as such.
That's also embodying
exactly who you are.
Your identity is your identity.
You own it, you work with it
and that's it and that's how you
have to go through life.
- Never waiver.
- Yeah. Cheers, cheers to that.
- Or compromise.
Cheers to that.
I couldn't get my home button to
work for 13 seconds this morning
and I freaked my shit.
(women laughing)
I was like dead.
I was like seriously,
did you catch that on
film or that was before?
- [DRock] No.
- That would have been funny.
- [DRock] They
have it upside-down.
I think this is
upside-down you guys.
- [Gary] It's
upside-down, right?
- [DRock] His
mic is upside-down.
Yeah.
- [Gary] Cool. Yes?
- [Woman] When you aren't a
first mover in an industry,
like Wine Library TV was, or a
social channel like Instagram,
Facebook, Twitter which all have
so many people on them now,
how do you go about
breaking through the noise?
- Talent.
(audience laughter)
- Some of the
questions will be short.
- You know why, (laughs),
you know why I'm excited?
I'm excited because I have a
lot of respect for this room.
There's a lot of
talent in this room.
Just 'cause you weren't first,
doesn't mean you can't be best.
Now remember,
best comes in two-fold.
It's why I made that point.
If you're actually great at
what you do for a living,
that's only part of it.
You have to be great
at communicating it
in the way it's
communicated today.
You have to understand angles
and pictures or what works in
video or how to use hashtags to
be discovered when nobody
knows who you are.
They both matter but shouldn't
you put in the work if
you get the benefit?
You know what I mean?
- [Woman] I do.
- [Gary] We are strong as shit.
We're really fucking strong,
we're just being sold that we're
not 'cause there's
a lot of money,
a lot of money in telling
us that we're not
pretty enough, thin enough,
smart enough, good enough.
Fuck that.
I want to tell you you're
the fucking best, go do shit.
(audience cheers and applause)
- I don't think you can end on
a higher note than fuck that.
(audience laughter)
- It was actually do shit.
("Unstopable" by
Moosh &amp; Twist)
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
Let's go, super fast.
Awesome, bye guys.
Selfie?
Awesome, thank you.
Yeah. Yeah.
That's awesome, thank you.
Is that right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Update it time.
Got it. Got it.
What I think in the short term,
the big thing that I want to
make sure is I'm not creating
any vulnerabilities for '17
scopes and the momentum I'm
creating with (censored).
Just want to make sure.
When I think
of (censored) today,
I think of it as in three parts.
I guess (censored)
being (censored) whatever like
without, obviously, I think a
lot the things that will bubble
up from emails that I've gotten
from (censored) of like hey,
what I sent you.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- So there's that, and I feel
like that's bubbling up again so
I want to get some clarity,
creative and strategy
and paid media.
Then macro issue is like I have
really intense next four or
five days, you know?
We (censored) specifically
I made such a
monumental bet on
and very honestly it's created
a little bit about financial
pickle for me that I'm dealing
with that I'm spending a lot of
time on personally right now.
And it's crippled me
in this short term
but I'm pumped
because I think the long
term really plays out.
("Midnight" by LRYBRDBTZ)
- What we're coming in and
saying now in 2017 is look
you're going to make
a big one or two
so instead of taking
(censored) for four videos
and making 29 do (censored)
for three videos
but do (censored)
for five, seven,
nine videos over here.
The thing that brands aren't
doing well is they're not giving
themselves enough
chances to win.
- [Man 4] Right.
- [Gary] That's it.
Five years ago you
guys were right.
It's that Facebook has the
actual distribution reach.
Alright, I got to
go see my wife.
- Guys, this was awesome.
- I'm fired up.
- Thank you.
- Have a good weekend.
- [Man 4] You too.
- Time to go or my
wife's gonna kill me.
Is that how you first saw me?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] That's one of my
favorites, you know what?
- [Garrett] It's
super underrated.
- Somebody look it up
right now, tell me the date,
we're doing an
anniversary edition.
- [Gary In Video]
How I make money?
Where am I gonna make money?
I just need to make money.
I get it.
It makes sense.
Monetizing is where
it's at, my friends.
That's why you have to do it.
(group laughter)
Google.
Look at old Google.
- [Garrett] Did
you search "beer"?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Gary In Video]
All these beer sites.
All these different beer sites.
Not jerking your chain,
you know what I mean?
- [Man In Video] Okay, yeah.
Google's the premiere way to
advertise just because
people are actively
searching for something.
- [Gary In Video] No question.
I think you're
doing a great job.
I think that if I had 500 to
2,000 people watching a
20 minute beer show every.
- Love you guys.
I really want, alright
DRock I'm out of here.
Just watched some nostalgia on
Friday night and
now I'm out of here.
The way you're gonna money while
the big boys may be out of your
league or you're not ready give
a PowerPoint presentation and
wear a tie and
go to Madison Avenue,
the way you're gonna make
money is by grabbing it.
("Midnight" by LRYBRDBTZ)